- But you're saying you
gotta deal with that
as if I gotta deal with
my Black life being lost,
because they can go home safe every night,
but I gotta worry about getting home--
- They chose that job!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- No justice!
- [Crowd] No peace!
- No racist!
- [Crowd] Police!
- Say his name!
- [Crowd] George Floyd!
- [Woman with Cap] Say his name!
- To respect the man who has a job,
and is only in danger because
he has to come to work
and he has to realize if
he's gonna go home or not.
- [Woman with Cap] Wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait.
Now you're getting into
waters that are talking--
- No, no, no, no, no, no.
- [Woman with Cap] You're
getting into waters--
I'm not taking sides!
- We've gotta get home to,
and it's about us right now!
- That's what makes you better,
because you have a conscience!
You got a conscience!
This what makes you better,
because you consciously think
about the next man's family
even when they don't care about you.
Rape you, spit on you, but you know what?
You don't let the circumstance change you.
- [Woman with Cap] What if they kill you?
- You know what?
You're better than that.
- [Woman with Cap] But you're dead!
- [Crowd] Yeah, you're dead!
- [Woman with Cap] You
can't go home, you're dead!
But you're saying you gotta deal with that
as if I gotta deal with
my Black life being lost,
because they can go home safe every night,
but I gotta worry about getting home--
- They chose that job!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- I didn't choose my skin color!
I didn't choose my skin color,
but they chose that job.
- No no no, this is to make you better
and I'ma tell you why.
Because we're not afraid of death.
- I am afraid of death!
I don't wanna die!
Black cops, White cops, Mexican cops,
it doesn't matter what race the cop is.
They're all part of the same
institutionalized racist system.
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- We constantly hear
"Fuck that, fuck this, vote him out."
Right?
But this isn't a voting issue.
This is an issue about voting.
If Biden comes in tomorrow,
it's gonna be the same issue
because this is based on a system
of institutionalized racism.
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- This is the United States
of Holding the Traditions
of White Supremacy and White Nationalism.
So when I heard you guys telling
the cops to walk with us,
I was looking at all of y'all different.
Because they're doing the same thing.
They can walk with us today,
but tomorrow they're still gonna
kill us in the street like animals.
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- This is not gonna
change with a simple vote!
The change comes from
revolutionary tactics.
The police system was
based off of slavery.
It started as slave markets.
The police system started as people
who went out to grab slaves.
Have you guys read the
Thirteenth Amendment?
Slavery was never abolished.
Look at the mass incarceration system!
There's multiple Black
and brown bodies there.
This system was built against us!
It was built against people like me.
So I'm tired, as a young Black woman,
knowing that tomorrow
if I get shot down dead,
it's gonna be the same thing.
The same hashtag.
But many of you guys treat
it like it's a trend.
Many of you guys treat
it like it's a hashtag.
This is not a hashtag, this is my life.
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- So frankly, I'm sick and
tired of the Instagram chains.
Just the "Black Lives Matter".
What are you doing at home?
Are you telling your racist parents
that their anti-Black behaviors are wrong?
Because if you're out here--
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- We're the ones that are
gonna bring the change.
So unless you're actually out
here to garner true change,
and if you're just gonna put a hashtag
on an Instagram chain,
fuck out of my face!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- This is not a joke!
This is not something
that's gonna end tomorrow.
that's gonna end next week.
And if you're treating it as
such, you do not belong here!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- Because White supremacy
helps people like Donald Trump.
It helps people like Joe Biden.
Hell, it even helped the
war criminal, fucking Obama!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- So we sit here and we protest,
but what are we actually gonna do?
Donate to crowdfunds.
Donate to bails.
Get people out of prisons.
But also if you're White,
and you're just here to start riots
and you're just here to spray
paint, what are you doing?
Because at the end of the
day, it's people like me,
it's people with this skin
color who get blamed for it!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- Where are the Black people
who give their friends the N-word pass?
Where are those friends, huh?
Are they standing up?
They get the perms, they
rock the box braids,
they rock the cornrows,
but they're not out here
representing Black people?
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- We're here to be heard.
So if it gets violent,
it started with them.
So I don't want you telling
me to walk with them.
I'm not walking with the cop
that could kill me tomorrow, okay?
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- And if you want to do that, go ahead,
but just know you're not of the cause,
you're part of the issue.
You're part of the problem.
- I have been shot at,
I have been aimed at,
I have been gassed, I watched
a young woman be dragged
by her fucking hair for resisting arrest
because she was exercising her
right to protest peacefully.
- If you're not Black
and you see Black people
walking down the street,
don't grab your purse tighter,
don't cross the street really quick,
don't stare at them scared.
Say hi!
- [Woman] That's right.
- Give them a word of encouragement.
Let them know to stay strong.
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- Let them know that they're not alone.
Let them know that you love them,
let them know that they're safe,
and I guarantee you
this perception we have
of Black people will probably change.
- To all my non-Black allies:
When you get in those positions of power,
use your privilege to help break down
this systematic racial--
(crowd cheering drowns out speaker)
- Can everybody please record this?
I have a message for my preschool teacher.
He was pretty racist towards me.
I was one of the only
Black kids at my preschool,
and he used to call me in
randomly into his office,
and he made me stand in the
corner, by myself, for hours.
I'm talking hours by myself!
But guess what?
I'm still here standing today.
I'm still here!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- I'm still here!
All those countless hours,
man, my legs are strong.
I'm still standing.
- [Woman] What's his name?
- Mr. Layman.
Mr. Layman, if you can hear me--
- [Man] Fuck you, Mr. Layman!
- I'm still here!
- [Crowd] (cheers)
- Every single situation
that I was in as a kid,
it was always blamed on me and my brother
because we were the only Black
kids in our neighborhood.
So we were always the
ones that were blamed on
and put on with all this shit,
and I'm so tired of just seeing
all this fucking negativity on the news.
All this shit, and nothing's
fucking being done with it!
I wanna yell this at the cops, too.
We want fucking change!
- Stand up to your friends
that don't think it's right!
Stand up to your families!
History has repeated itself over and over
and over again that good will win!
Please keep going.
Do not give up.
When you think it is over, it is not!
- I basically want people to know
that it's not just from
being shot in the street
because you're Black and brown.
It goes further than that, okay?
We've been dealing with this for too long
where nothing could change, okay?
It's hard for my people to
get jobs over other folks,
it's hard for us to get loans,
and I'm talking about
school loans, house loans,
like all the way across the board, okay?
I want people to wake up.
Wake up, and realize that it
takes everybody being together.
It takes not just us trying to stand up,
but it takes the White
folks, it takes the Italians,
it takes the Asians!
It takes everybody that's
in this melting pot,
everybody to come together
and make this thing good.
I mean, I've got a million and one times
where I've been treated funny
just because of who I am.
But I'm a military veteran,
I'm a college graduate,
and y'know, I'm nonviolent,
and I love people,
and I'm just trying to
really get a better message
so that way we can elevate the humankind
to the next level instead of just
running around like rats
like we've been doing.
- I mean, I don't get it.
They're murdering us, then
telling us to be quiet
about them killing us.
It comes to a point in time
where you have to stop
caring about skin color
and start caring about
the war that we are in.
I know a lot of people don't want to think
that it's a war, but look around you.
Look at the riots that's
happening across the country now.
It is becoming a war, and yes,
you're gonna have to
fight for your freedom.
We're not special.
Like any other countries that you see
that are tired of their
governments, what do they do?
They turn around and they fight,
they fight for their fucking lives.
I think Americans, Black,
White, Hispanic, whatever,
are starting to see that there
is no other choice coming
but to fight for your lives.
We're being peaceful out
here, and in a couple of hours
they're going to send the bean bags,
they're gonna send the tear gas,
and they're gonna shoot
at us for being peaceful.
So if you don't see how that
is ridiculous, then you sleep!
And, I mean, keep sleeping
until everybody dead.
That's it, thank you.
- The overall message
that I want to send is
"Stop killing us.
"Just stop."
That's all I wanna say,
is just fucking stop.
- I'd rather die by the Coronavirus
than die at the hands of police.
- I'm Black, I matter, and I'm trans.
I fear for my life every
day, but I'm out here
and I'm here with you guys.
Black lives matter, all lives matter,
and trans lives matter as well.
- We're not trying to riot,
but rioting is just like,
the process of what we're getting through
and what we're going
through, rioting happened.
Like, we're not here to
riot and we're not here
to break stuff, but people
are so angry and like,
this has been going on for years
that this just happened, y'know.
- I want people to know that
being oppressed for 400 years
does something to people,
no matter who you are,
and the fact that people are just focusing
on the buildings being destroyed
instead of the Black
lives that have been lost
is just kind of sickening.
Cause like, you can't bring back a life
but you can rebuild a building,
and America needs to wake up
and see this is not for anything.
Black people are trying
to get a message out
for people to be heard,
because peaceful protesting.
We've been doing that for years
and they haven't heard us,
but now they're hearing us
because we're making some noise.
- People ask me, like,
"What do you think needs to change?
"Why does this keep on happening?"
And I know it keeps happening
because when you look at any thing,
person, animal, as lesser than you,
it's easy to treat them as such.
So I'm mixed, I'm half Black, half White.
One time, I was in Columbus, Ohio.
It was me, my brother,
and my cousin who's Black.
I just so happened to have
the hoodie on that day,
and we were walking in a mall.
And as we were walking, I
didn't know there were police
at the time, say
"Hey, get against the wall!"
I'm like,
"No, why would I get against the wall?"
and tried to walk around them.
They threw me to the ground.
My cousin jumped in, they
beat him up pretty bad.
I didn't know how that
affected me as a child
because I was 13, but as I get
older and seeing these things
keep on happen over and over again,
it made me realize that me,
someone who's not dark-skinned,
I can only imagine
if I was a dark-skinned
Black person how they have
to navigate through this
world and get profiled.
I think it's just really important for us
to educate ourselves on
things that aren't so surface.
Ask the hard questions of why things are
the way that they are.
- I'm out here for Black Lives Matter
and Trans Lives Matter, and
it's really important to me
because I'm also part
of the LGBTQ community
and we've also been getting hurt
by a lot of the police brutality
that has been going on.
- I just really can't
even believe the fact
that just a week ago, or
a couple of weeks ago,
you had people protesting
the quarantine wearing a mask
because they wanted a haircut,
with full armed rifles,
guns with loaded ammunition,
but we're out here
protesting peacefully,
but people want to gas us
and make it violent and
all that extra stuff
that's just not needed.
One of the main reasons that
I'm out here is for my brother.
My brother doesn't get
the same privilege as me.
I'm Black and I'm a
female, my brother is Black
and he's a male, and he faces
stereotyping and all that,
especially because he has tattoos,
so his life is 10 times
more harder than me.
He gets profiled, and
when he leaves the house,
I'm not sure if he's coming
home to us in one piece.
We never know.
So, that's why I'm out here.
- We are tired.
We are exhausted that
we even have to protest
during a global pandemic.
We just want peace, and
we just want justice.
That's all we want, and
that's all we've ever wanted.
There are people who are
taking these protests
as chances to live out
their riot fantasies,
but this isn't what we're about.
We're about peace, and
we just want justice
for everyone who has died mercilessly.
- We just want to let you guys know
that silence speaks volumes.
- [Woman With Cap] No justice!
- [Crowd] No peace!
- [Woman With Cap] No racist!
- [Crowd] Police!
Say his name!
- [Crowd] George Floyd!
- [Woman with Cap] Say his name!